direction le venezuela où le peuple est
toujours aussi nombreux dans les rues
malgré le confinement instauré dans
l'ensemble du territoire alors que le
pays d'amérique du sud a déploré son
premier décès lié au cours d'un virus
des files d'attentes pour entrer dans
les supermarchés sont à n'en plus finir
comme ici dans la banlieue de caracas
les vénézuéliens a qui ont du mal à
accepter d'être calfeutré à leur
domicile et ce n'est pas la mini carte
et pour moi c'est une punition parce que
je n'ai pas l'habitude je suis habitué à
sortir tous les jours pour faire mes
affaires pour faire les choses dont j'ai
besoin
c'est difficile de rester chez soi
comment cacher cette réalité c'est
difficile je ne veux pas tu ici
aujourd'hui
mais qu'est-ce que je peux faire je dois
être ici parce que c'est comme ça je
dois acheter de la nourriture je ne veux
pas mais que puis-je faire
l'expérience est bonne parce qu'on sort
dans la rue et qu'on voit des gens avec
des masques avec des gants ça veut dire
qu'il ya un niveau de sécurité pour nous
garder en bonne santé dans la rue on va
chercher à manger et en même temps on
nous protège